Сегодня я хотел бы с вами поговорить о
том что всегда делают Бедные люди и
никогда не делают богатые люди очень
многие люди хотят стать богатыми но в то
же время они делают те действия которые
никогда не сделают их богатыми многие
люди спрашивают что нужно сделать чтобы
стать богатым на самом деле прежде всего
Перестаньте делать то что делают бедные
и таким образом вы быстрее разбогатеет
Об этом я хотел бы сегодня поговорить в
этом видео я собрал девять вещей девять
вещей которые всегда делают бедные и
никогда не дела богатые люди и причём
это не имеет значения Какая
национальность какие страны во всём мире
происходит одно и тоже бедные это делают
всегда богатые это делают никогда Итак
поехали по пунктам первое жить не по
средствам это то что Бедные люди делают
как правило всегда жить не по средствам
- это
когда люди покупают какие-то
вещи которые не могут себе позволить
вообще не понимаю людей которые берут на
кредитные деньги там
на кредитные деньги берут машины А самое
худшее проявление этого это когда на
кредитные деньги проводят свадьбы или
какие-то мероприятия это просто пряме
путь к бедности и нищете и богатые люди
этого не делают как правило свойство
богатых людей и почему они стали
богатыми потому что они умеют жить
посредствам если брать причину почему
Бедные люди живут не по средствам Ну
возьмём ту жет же например со свадьбой
или покупкой автомобилей в кредит Это
потому что Бедные люди преследуют чужие
цели они хотят чтобы как было как у
людей чтобы было как у людей это первая
причина Если вы хотите перестать быть
бедным первый шаг Определите свои цели и
Следуйте своим целям а не чужим А ваша
цель ведь стать богатым а не купить
автомобиль или провести свадьбу на
кредит и Вторая причина почему бедные
это делают потому что очень часто Бедные
люди не понимают цену владения вот Что
такое объясню на простом примере Вот вы
покупаете автомобиль условно за там
50.000 долларов и Бедные люди думают что
это вот это вот это есть их затраты а на
самом деле их затраты - это не 50.000
долларов 50.000 долларов - это только
первые затраты А дальше пошли налоги
дальше
пошли стоимость запчастей этого
автомобиля стоимость расходных
материалов бензина смазки и так далее То
есть и пошло поехало когда покупаете
любую вещь обязательно Думайте о том
какова цена владения этой вещью второй
пункт Бедные люди всегда пытаются
экономить и сберегать а богатые люди в
основном стараются инвестировать и вот
здесь кардинальная разница и это
происходит во всех странах Дело в том
что если вы будете работать над
сокращением своих расходов то это такая
сужающая воронка вы
сокращая ваших расходов удивительным
образом будет происходить падение ваших
доходов поэтому есть такое знаменитое
изречение которое приписывают рокфеллеру
которая гласит Не бойтесь больших
расходов бойтесь маленьких доходов это
как раз то правило согласно которому
живут богатые люди Бедные люди пытаются
экономить и где-то сберегать откладывать
на депозит и так далее богатые люди всё
время пытаются инвестировать это два
разных подхода поэтому всегда Работайте
над увеличением капитала ещё ни один
человек не стал богатым благодаря
депозитам и ни один человек не стал
богатым благодаря экономии все богатые
люди становились таковыми Только
благодаря увеличению доходов и третий
пункт это нежелание обучаться и
развиваться как правило бедность она не
является чем-то Что давно не заслуженно
или несправедлива как правило бедность
является показателем определённых
пороков которых чело есть например
гордыня когда он считает что он всё
знает либо лень когда он не хочет
чему-то учиться новому либо зависть
когда он не хочет чтобы у других было
там но и сам не хочешь развиваться и так
далее вот отличие Я заметил во всех
странах бедных и богатых в том что
богатые люди - это как правило те люди
которые постоянно развиваются и это
смотрите зачастую даже Бывает так что
это не свойство характера А это свойство
активности богатых людей люди достаточно
активны из-за своей активности они
делают много действий из-за этих
действий они совершают много ошибок и
неудач ошибки неудачи являются основным
драйвером саморазвития Вполне возможно
что богатые люди становятся такими
благодаря своей активности и получению
многих уроков от своих ошибок и неудач
Бедные люди как правило они избегают
рисков и они как
правило не хотят обучаться и развиваться
это может быть благодаря каким-то своим
неправильным или будем так говорить
а нехорошим человеческим качествам либо
благодаря тому что человек не хочет
брать на себя риски и развиваться
четвёртое что бедные делают всегда и
богатый никогда это вариться в том же
самом окружении Я заметил что успешные
люди постоянно меняют среду в которой
они общаются они легко заводят
знакомства они встречаются они ездят на
какие-то выставки конференции форумы они
легко входят в Контакт с незнакомыми
людьми в то время как Бедные люди как
правило зажимаются у них какие-то
комплексы они боятся подходить к кому-то
они боятся кому-то с кем-то знакомиться
И это объяснимо потому что у них низкая
самооценка они думают ой если я сейчас
подойду меня могут послать или со мной
может не так обойтись и так далее но
здесь тоже есть объяснение Почему люди в
основном боятся подходить Потому что им
внутрення гордыня не позволяет А как
работает гордыня гордыня не позволяет им
получить отказ потому что отказ для них
очень больно воспринимается и поэтому
люди Бедные люди как правило не подходят
знакомиться к другим потому что боятся
получить Отказ А отказ очень больно бьёт
по их гордыне Если вы чувствуете и
видите в себе эти качества прямо
преодолевай в зародыше просто Возьмите
себя за правила если я хочу стать
богатым я должен знакомиться Я должен не
бояться подходить другим людям я должен
не бояться получать отказ И кстати
отсутствие страха или Преодоление страха
от получение отказа является первым
навыком которые
отрабатывают в своей профессии продавцы
Если вы не научитесь получать отказ и не
научитесь на него правильно реагировать
вы никогда никому не сможете что-либо
продать
пятое то что делают бедные и не делают
богаты люди то что Бедные люди живут как
правило одним днём они действуют
реактивно сначала наступает события и
они действуют и таким образом они всё
время как бы решают проблемы которые
каждый день У них появляются и
появляются у бедных людей даже нет
времени А планировать далеко и самое
интересное Если у вас нету времени
планировать и ставить долгосрочные цели
то это время у вас никогда так и не
появится вы будете как белка в колесе
всё время крутиться в своём колесе Я
заметил что у бедных людей очень
краткосрочный горизонт планирования если
он вообще есть зачастую у бедных людей
планирование Нет вообще как такового
поэтому жить одним днём - это качество
присущее бедным людям богатые люди как
правило имеют цели имеют планы и не
просто планы они имеют планы
долгосрочные шестой пункт которые присущ
бедным людям и как правило которые не
делают богатые люди бедные люди в
основном фокусируются на проблемах они
не могут посмотреть над проблемой и не
могут тем более увидеть в проблемах
возможности Когда у вас в жизни
происходят проблемы то не спешите
огорчаться в первую очередь постарайтесь
задать себе вопрос и сказать хорошо это
проблема а какие возможности Она за
собой несёт и держите фокус не на
проблеме держите фокус на её решении и
на тех возможностей которые она может
для вас открыть вот Я заметил у богатых
людей свойство такое что они в каждой
проблеме ищут возможность Да острота
проблемы для них от этого меньше не
становится но они понимают что за каждой
проблемой обычно есть какая-то
возможность более того в исламе
говорится что за каждым испытанием А
проблема - это испытания всегда
обязательно Аллах даёт какое-то благо
поэтому научитесь в любой проблеме в
любом испытании увидеть благо если Вы
согласны с таким принципам то
обязательно ставьте лайки и слушаем
дальше седьмое Что обычно делают бедные
и не делают богатые Бедные люди не
готовы рисковать это объяснимо у них и
так мало ресурсов чем им рисковать Но с
другой стороны можно на эту же ситуацию
посмотреть под другим углом зрения и
сказать раз у вас так и так терять
нечего почему бы вам не рисковать как
раз-таки вам и надо рисковать потому что
вам терять нечего и ещё второй момент
Бедные люди неправильно понимают риски
они риски как возможность потери а
богатые люди воспринимают риски как
возможность разбогатеть видите на один и
тот же фактор разные взгляды поэтому
научитесь брать риски и не просто
необдуманно брать риски этого как
раз-таки у бедных людей достаточно вот
есть категории людей бедных которые
риски не берут А есть категории которые
берут риски но берут необдуманно важно
здесь понимать что надо брать риски и
риски которые имеют во-первых а хорошие
шансы а второе имеют хороший выхлоп вот
нужно брать риски имеющие высокие шансы
и риски а которые дают большой выхлоп
Или большую отдачу в случае
а если ситуация сложится в вашу пользу
наверняка в вашей жизни были случаи
когда вы рискнули и у вас получилось и
вы Прямо кайфанул от этого так вот
Разберите этот случай для того чтобы
понимать какой риск вы на себя взяли Это
был обдуманный риск или необдуманный и
была ли высока вероятность Удачного
Исхода у этого риска или нет И потом
извлеките уроки и Повторяйте Повторяйте
такие действия обязательно напишите свою
историю с принятием рисков внизу в
комментариях восьмой пункт - это искать
виноватых в своих проблемах в чём
проблема этого пункта Дело в том что вот
я заметил такую вещь что у бедных людей
всегда кто-то или что-то виновато в их
проблемах это может быть погода это
может быть пробки это может быть Дефицит
какой-то это может быть правительство
президент Аким там начальник Сосед и так
далее они всегда и во всём видят
виноватых во вне в чём проблема такого
подхода Дело в том что когда вы видите
виновных на стороне вне вас то есть вы
не берёте ответственность на себя за
свои действия за свою жизнь за всё что с
вами происходит то вам нету смысла
меняться потому что зачем вам меняться
если виноват он если виноваты погодные
условия если виноваты обстоятельства
Зачем меняться вам а раз Вы не меняетесь
вы по кругу ходите остаётесь в той же
среде с вами постоянно что-то случается
А когда вы берёте ответственность за
свою жизнь на себя и вы говорите да я
вышел даже под дождь и промок не дождь
виноват я виноват я не взял плащ или не
взял зонт и так далее вы сразу же уже в
голове возникает Следующий вопрос А что
мне нужно сделать чтобы в будущем это не
повторилось А это тот первый вопрос с
которого начинается саморазвитие поэтому
что бы не происходило в вашей жизни
Какие бы не благожелательный события не
происходили никогда ни в чём не вините
ни других людей ни обстоятельства берите
ответственность на свою жизнь и
задавайте себе Следующий вопрос А что
мне нужно сделать чтобы этого со мной не
было девятый пункт
в основном очень часто или почти всегда
делают Бедные люди и не делают богатые
люди Они сливают время в пустую К
сожалению Бедные люди не ценят своё
время не ценят свою энергию не ценят
своё внимание поэтому они очень часто и
много сливают своё время ресурсы я имею
в виду когда ресурсы - это время и
энергию и своё внимание впустую Они
висят в социальных сетях смотрят разные
видосики мемы tiktok ведут праздные
беседы обсуждают кого-то сплетничают
участвуют в различных левах и так далее
То есть таким образом сливает время
впустую а Даже те кто не сливает время
впустую они очень низко ценят своё время
свою энергию и своё внимание и таким
образом они остаются бедными вот это то
что не отпускает бедных людей и держит
их вот в этом состоянии поэтому учитесь
ценить А что значит научитесь ценить это
не значит что вы сейчас выходите и
говорите другим людям Ой я не готов
работать За эту цену Я моя цена другая
вам не будут давать работу вы вообще без
работы тогда останетесь когда я говорю
научитесь ценить своё время а энергию и
внимание это значит вместо того чтобы
впустую проводить их лучше это время
Энергия и внимание инвестируйте в своё
саморазвитие и приобретение новых
навыков умений и знаний внимание время и
энергия потраченные на саморазвитие
приведут вас к отдаче виде более
дорогостоящей работы конечно те эти
пункты которые я сегодня для вас
перечислил они требуют определённых
усилий но вы знаете Никто вам не сказал
что жизнь - это такая комфортная
прогулка ведь недаром есть Народная
пословица жизнь прожить не поле перейти
Если вы не хотите смириться со своей
ситуацией со своим состоянием тогда Вы
должны делать то что делают богатые люди
Это причём вопрос даже не богатства
вопрос в том чтобы не оставаться в том
где вы находитесь А если вы конечно
довольны и счастливы тем что вы имеете и
довольны и счастливы тем состоянием в
котором вы находитесь то конечно же
продолжайте делать то что вы делаете
ведь в конечном счёте наша цель или цель
нашей жизни - это немного денег а
прожить счастливую жизнь